learning needs to be joyful I'm
Catherine manga award for reason TV I'm
speaking with Chris Anderson he was the
curator of TED Talks thanks for taking
about to talk with us Chris thank you so
tell me about why we should be excited
about the edification of education what
I spoke about today and what I
passionately believe is that education
starts with one key question is there a
spark there is their curiosity there you
know what when it's world where there's
there's all of the world's knowledge is
available to someone who's curious
summon it to your screen your phone your
computer whatever but curiosity is hard
because there's so many distractions so
the things we would like kids to be
curious about they often aren't and and
it just doesn't work to kind of smack
them over the head with the hammer so I
think I think Ted ed is really an
experiment in trying to nurture
curiosity it's trying to we we do
several things but they're all aimed at
that one goal can you ignite the spark
and it's true that the most popular TED
talk ever is actually about this sort of
lack of creativity and curiosity
education right or is that what is it
about that that made people say I gotta
click on this and watch it so yes the
number one TED talk ever is Sir Ken
Robinson talking about creativity and
scores and it's it's a heartfelt plea
that creativity should be nurtured and
supported why is it the most popular in
Ted's history probably cuz it's
incredibly funny and here's just a
brilliant speaker it's full of hilarious
anecdotes about kids doing crazy things
but it it ends with with just a
beautiful Powerball and it's it ends
with the story of Andrew Lloyd Webber's
choreographer who discovered that far
from being educationally subnormal she
was a dancer and she just needed to
celebrate her creativity and when she
moved to a dance school and had those
skills taken seriously she found who she
was and that person thrived and I guess
there are a lot of people out there who
feel that their school
down and that they weren't given a
chance to really be who they wanted to
be why are you here other than the kind
of Ted EDD project I mean is there
something about the school reform
movement such as it is that fits in with
what you see your mission at Ted or is
it more of a personal interest you how
do you fit in with this crowd which is
you know largely it's sort of a wonky
policy state legislature oriented group
Ted's mission his ideas worth spreading
and the most important part of that
mission logically has to be kids I mean
there are their minds aren't fully wired
yet they have their whole lives ahead of
them ideas matter more for them than for
anyone so in reg occations become a
bigger and bigger part of our focus are
our passion and so that's why I'm here
and and I i think you know we a
nonpartisan were not really involved in
the detailed policy debates and so forth
but we do think that education needs
radical reform and that learning needs
to be joyful you know like we the whole
the whole experience of learning from a
great teacher can be the most thrilling
thing on earth it's it's heartbreaking
that in so many classrooms that isn't
happening and so we think that what
where ted has been most thrilling is
when you find a teacher who is really
good at what they do and you give them
this platform and then suddenly in a
week they have they have reached tens of
thousands of kids one in their whole
life up to that point they've reached a
thousand or fewer that's that's special
do you do you buy I mean obviously you
can't be a full skeptic of this sort of
concern about screen time for kids or
video replacing actual instruction I
think you've just made a very good case
for why that's true in part do you buy
any of that critique though do you think
there is something lost or dangerous or
sinister about not just the video form
but also perhaps the sort of abbreviated
sexy glossy 15 minute 10 form um what
can't be lost is is the human contact I
mean the talk i just gave right I said
that what what what technology might do
is empower two different kinds of
teaching you know subject based teaching
where a subject is explained brilliantly
and passionately and people kind of
inspired at that level of boy now I get
this this has come alive in my mind I
now know I want to be historian or
economy I never knew that before I was
so bored by this before but now I get it
so there's there's that but the but it
can't be just that the the human teacher
who who sits down with the care to looks
at them and sees that they're upset or
stressed or worried and has some issue
puts their arm around there maybe and
listens to them and tries to encourage
them and take them forward I mean that
has to be part of teaching as well I
believe and the argument is that the
technology can allow more of that not
less that that by by outsourcing some of
the subject instructional part to the
world's greatest teachers that you the
person with this kid right here can
spend more time on 121 is there any
specific single or maybe cluster of
policy proposals that would make your
mission easier so I mean I think
everyone has ideas about how to improve
education but like is there a law that's
in your way is there a regulation that's
bothering you are you worried about
internet regulate I mean what is there
anything on the policy side that you're
like oh
this one thing we're not you know when
nonpartisan we stay out of the policy
debates as much as we can we are
currency is ideas passion and curiosity
excitement so we basically want to put a
bunch of tools out there and let people
do with them what they what they will
we're a non-profit we've got no you know
money-making motive or any other motive
it's just it's just look in the
connected age that we're in these tools
dear teacher may help you in your in
your mission to teach better would you
like to use them and I'm gonna think
they're compatible with with many
different policies and I think they are
in many ways they operate at a more
granular level that you know if if if
you believe that schools should spend
more time you know with a flipped
classroom or in some other way you
should be able to use these tools in
some way but it's it's not we don't
really know yet or take it no it has to
be this way we don't know how to
organize a school we just think that the
way which schools organized probably
needs to change quite dramatically what
is your best case scenario for for for
teddy like what when you sort of look to
let's say five years in the future is it
is it kind of a sea of classrooms with
kids watching ted videos is there
something more that you're sort of your
next phase might be what's you know
what's your long-term vision i think one
of the most beautiful things that could
come out of it is the co-creation by
thousands of teachers around the world
of an archive of lessons that are freely
terrible where the best work of a
teacher has been combined with video
resources that are available so the way
the way out some of our tools work is
that any teacher can assemble their own
lesson out of for example a youtube
video and then add questions to it and
so forth those best lessons can be used
by the teacher but they can also be
shared so i think i think the
the whole reason that that Ted itself is
worked in the last few years has been
because the crowd has got involved you
know they've they've that's why talks
have been shared across the world that's
why our TEDx fingers spread so I really
I just really believe in this power of
open and so to provide tools that allow
teachers to help each other that that I
think would be the best outcome and you
know we're excited it progress so far